Hi, everyone, I'm head of development for
an online platform for showcasing and discovering
creative work.
I want to share about our journey of growing
and maintaining a large codebase in an area
where front-end technology is changing extremely
fast, from our original days of using vanilla
CSS through to the introduction of preprocessors,
and into our current day in JS implementations.
I will go over some of our trials and tribulations,
growing pains, and I will even air some of
our dirty laundry, but, perhaps most importantly,
how I learned to stop worrying and love the
website.
The front-end web development ecosystem is
moving insanely fast these days.
It seems like a new tool or methodology for
authoring HTML, CSS, and JavaScript becomes
available every other day.
Whereas a few years ago, there weren't nearly
as many tools with which to work on these
things, probably in large part because complex
front-end requirements like responsive web
development, or single-page web apps weren't
even concerns near our radars yet.
Now we are seeing huge rapid advancements
in the languages themselves to how we generate
basically every single kind of code we write,
to the frameworks we use to organise our code,
all the way to the build tools that we use
to build, compile, optimise, and serve our
code.
Because there's always some better or faster
tool becoming available, it can feel overwhelming
to choose and adopt these new technologies
all the time.
This is hard enough to do on a brand new project,
where there is no pre-exist ing code concerns,
but it can be especially hard in a large codebase,
or one has been around for a long time.
Where, when the moment you add something new,
suddenly, everything else becomes legacy code,
and now, not only do you have all of this
new stuff that you need to learn and maintain,
you also have to consider how it's going to
play with all of your old code, and how or
even if you're ever going to update that old
code to use this new stuff.
When you compound these technical challenges
with the industry pressure that you should
be using a certain tool, or doing things a
certain way in order to be a real web developer,
it can create kind of a harsh environment
for being able to make the best decisions
for your team and for your product, and for
your users.
Which, on the code side, that can lead to
things like an increase in technical debt,
or missed project deadlines, but on the human
side of things, it can create negative feelings
like imposter syndrome or burn-out which are
really harmful.
Today, I want to tell you about how we've
dealt with these kinds of challenges over
the years, and, if any of you have felt like
you've experienced anything like these, or
might experience anything like this, I want
you to know you're not alone.
We've been involving the codebase since 2010.
When I joined the team eight years ago, they
had finished a wholesale rewrite of the website
from scratch but since then we've not started
over but working in the same evolving codebase
through the years, and we've moved through
a number of different template engines, CSS
pro processors, JavaScript libraries and frameworks
- you name it.
I joined as the fourth developer on the team,
and, since then, we've grown to be about 40
developers, and, in that time, we have faced
a really wide variety of challenges.
We are also constantly considering which new
technologies we can use which will serve us
and the website and the users' needs best.
We have had to figure out how to actually
implement these new technologies into our
existing track, even when there were massive
functional disparities with what was already
there.
We have had to figure out when to start implementing
these things, in particular, having to balance
our product goals, and road maps with our
developer happiness as well as the health
of the codebase.
We have had to clean up any messes we left
behind along the way.
So, there is a ton of opinions out there on
the internet on what the best or the right
way to build a website is.
I'm not here to tell you that there is any
one right or wrong way to do any of these
things.
In fact, I'm kind of here to demonstrate the
opposite.
What I do want to tell you is about how we've
handled these challenges over the years, how
and why we've made the decisions that we did,
and how they did or did not work out for us.
And what I really kind of want to reveal is
that, no matter how pretty and put-together
things may seem from the outside, whenever
you pull back the curtain, there's no website
or process as perfect or pretty as it may
seem.
So, first, a little extra insight into our
size and complexity.
As of today, I counted 50 pages on our website
which exist in various states of logged in
our out, or empty states or not, and that's
made up of over 500 JavaScript files, roughly
the same number of style sheets and almost
1,000 markup templates.
Of course, this nuclear missile has been in
- this number has been in flux over the years
as we've removed various pages and sections
of the site, but the website has also evolved
to become a little bit more like a WhatsApp
as opposed to its - like a web app as opposed
to its traditional website origins, we have
way more interactive modular components that
exist across many of the site - for example,
a notifications and a messages feed that you
can see on any page, like a project pop-up
or user card that can be incited from many
different areas of the website as well.
We have humble begins.
This screen shot is from the Way Back Machine.
There used to be something on the right side.
Some things get lost even to the internet.
Back in 2010 when I first joined, we weren't
using anything but CSS to satisfactorily the
website.
I would - to style the website.
I would say our CSS style back then could
be called copy-paste-driven development at
this point.
We pretty much had no tools on the front-end
to help us reduce repetition, or weren't using
any methodologies or naming conventions to
help keep our CSS clean.
This is what the website looked like, and
I would say anything on the website that wasn't
plain text or a solid colour was probably
an image.
CSS just wasn't nearly as robust as it is
today, and we were trying to create something
more visually interesting than native CSS
would allow at the time.
We started to get comfortable using CSS features
for visual flair where we could, understanding
the website didn't have to look the same in
every single browser all the time, and once
our designers realised that we could make
any CSS gradient we wanted without them having
to make images for it, I got to become intimately
familiar with this tool.
There is like a dozen different ways to make
gradients in different browsers, and I was
not about to memorise all that syntax.
In time, browser technology started to pick
up more seam.
CSS as a language was advancing, and we were
having a lot of fun with the cool visual visual
tricks and treats with CSS and getting comfortable
with making images starting to implement with
native CSS.
We had an interesting additional challenge
in that we also had all of these offshoots
of the site that were themed galleries for
different creative fields and these white-label
almost miniature Behance's school and organisations
which used the same markup and JavaScript
with the main website but with an additional
style sheet loaded to customise them for their
own look for brand.
All these lived within the same one codebase
which means if you changed something in the
main website, you had to make sure you didn't
change it on the other 40-plus versions of
the website.
No big deal.
So, by now, we had a clear need of a tool
that would help us with our CSS development.
Not only were vendor prefixes starting to
slip through the cracks, but thanks to the
themed galleries and websites, we were inundated
with copy and pasted CSS where largely the
differences were font names or colour values.
Fortunately which by this time, CSS processors
were picking up steam looking like the perfect
tool to make, more dry.
Now, the story I'm about to tell is not about
the merits of any one CSS preprocessor over
the other, but I do want to use it was a real-world
example of the messy path to choosing, implementing,
and using new tools.
For us, we were debating between Less and
Sass, good tools on their own, but wanted
to make sure we picked the tool for our specific
needs.
Sass had more compelling implementations and
features for our use case and Compass on top
of that offered a ton of extra power that
was going to be absolutely perfect for all
those sites and our sprite management.
Sass and Compass were set to improve our lives
drastically.
The answer could not be more clear.
We obviously went with Less!
Why we would do that?
For a couple of of reasons: the time, there
was only Ruby Sass, and since the site was
not built on a Ruby stack, it wasn't easy
for us to implement or even start using Sass
and it was a little bit in Tim dating.
Since Less could be compiled by downloading
a GUI app to your computer, it had a low barrier
of entry for us.
We were still a tiny dev team at this point,
but this meant we could start getting a lot
of the benefits of a CSS preprocessor sooner
and way less friction and engineering time
than if we had chosen to go with Sass at that
point.
It afforded us another interesting benefit
as well in that we were able to use Less as
a proof of concept that implement be a CSS
preprocessor was a worthwhile investment.
The time it took to get it up and running
for everyone to use paid off drastically in
development time and development improvements
down the line which meant that we were able
to get more team buy-in for actually adopting
Sass as well as negotiate for the development
time that we needed to do so and make the
switch to the tool that we ultimately felt
would serve us best.
But our journey does not end there.
Although we had decided that the higher-end
investment in setting up Sass was worth it,
we had to cut some corners to get there.
To complicate things, we were now dealing
with the dreaded technical debt of working
in a codebase that had partially vanilla CSS
and partially less syntax, and now we would
have to spend the time to convert that all
into Sass.
We still didn't have a tech stack that could
compile Sass for us, but what we could do
was install Ruby and Sass on each of our individual
computers and compile and commit the Sass
and the CSS to our repositories from there.
Now, we violated a lot of web development
best practices by compiling CSS on our own
machines instead of by using a build tool
within the tech stack, and we were committing
an even worse crime of actually committing
exiled code to our repository.
I seriously doubt you would ever find a Medium
think-piece advocating for this kind of implementation,
and gives me some anxiety to admit on stage
in front of you all that we were committing
such an egregious violation of best practice
by having literally hundreds of preprocessed
CSS files in our library.
On the flip side, I can't tell you how much
benefit we were having by having Sass available
for us in this way.
For what sounds like a nightmare situation
on the surface, I have to say, for the most
part, actually it worked really well for us.
Suddenly, we were able to build our themed
galleries in white-labelled website in a fraction
of the time which meant that we were helping
our users in our mission to give more exposure
to creatives.
We were able to do it with way less code than
before which meant that now our codebase became
much easier to understand and maintain.
Although committing compiled code is considered
a bad practice, for a large, complex codebase
with a lot of interdependencies, it actually
ended up giving us extremely clear visibility
into the reach that any single change actually
was having.
In the - and the last cool thing is that we
suddenly had tools that could do grunt work
for us.
For example, this meant that our designers
could focus on working on and designing things
that actually mattered rather than spending
their time doing menial tasks like stitching
sprites together.
We were able to find a balance between a subpar
implementation, as well as code health by
reducing a lot of the technical debt in our
CSS.
But what happens when you need a tool that
doesn't really seem to exist yet?
Around this time, we started working on a
new product.
It was a single-page web app for task management
we called Method Action Online.
Given it was a totally new product, we were
starting from scratch, and we had an excellent
and rare opportunity to try out new technologies.
We got to do this without having to worry
about retrofitting it into any existing code.
I think we chose Less for this one because
of the timing but on the JavaScript side,
we ended up making the decision to write our
own JavaScript framework which we called nbdd.js.
We built it at a time when Angular and Backbone
were extremely popular well established frameworks.
Why we would bother writing our own?
If you look at this timeline, we were actually
doing this at a time when there weren't a
ton of alternative options, or the ones that
were out were kind of new.
Adopting a Jung technology in a product that
you anticipate and hope is going to live for
years is kind of a non-zero-risk move.
Now, I'm not saying that writing your own
framework or using an existing one is better
or worse than the other, but for the size
of our team and the needs of our product at
the time, being able to its operate on our
own front-end framework - iterate on our own
front-end framework is precisely what we needed
at the time.
Action Method Online became a good proving
ground for our JavaScript framework because
it was born go and forged for specific interactive
and data-driven purposes, we were actually
able to apply the techniques and practices
that we learned in Action Method Online back
on Behance.
We were able to use complex features this
framework for uploading be and editing features
we could add to Behance as well.
By this time, Behance was evolving from its
static website roots to become more responsive
and a bit more modular, but execute be this
kind of huge paradigm shift was a tremendous
undertaking for us.
There was literally nothing about how the
site was built to that point that was conducive
to being responsive.
The way we built the site layout was rigid,
the existing design was not immediately adaptable
to smaller screen sizes, and we were still
lacking the tools on the front-end that we
need to structure and implement the kind of
responsive functionality and modularity that
we really wanted to.
We knew we wanted to make the website responsive
but despite the challenges in place by the
existing foundation, we knew a full rewrite
of the website was out of the question.
It was a huge website and would have have
taken far too long.
So we continued working on Behance.
We would add new features and convert the
site over to be responsive page by page, and
we used our JavaScript framework NBD for any
new code that we were creating, and updating
existing areas of the site needed also, whether
it was because that page was due for maintenance
or any other kind of update.
So, both Sass and NBD carried us all the way
into 2015 when we started working on another
brand new single-page web app.
This time it was a website builder called
the W portfolio and turned to be the most
complex single web app we've created to date.
We had a ton of new technical challenges on
portfolio that we never had to deal with before
in our single-page web app.
We wanted to build a few GUI what you see
is what you get editor, building where one
of any literally hundreds of customisation
dialogues, you could make a change to your
website and see it reflected in the editor
in real time.
We needed to do this while maintaining an
editor chrome that didn't interfere with user
customisations in any way.
We started building Portfolio with NBD but
building and maintaining a framework is not
without its risks and downsides, either.
Now, we had started to feel the growing pains
of using our own home-grown framework.
It was originally build by one of our developers
and maintained by only a couple of more, so
this meant that it didn't move particularly
fast.
It meant that other open-source frameworks
were moving at a much faster rate.
It also meant that it was much more challenging
for new hires to learn it.
Documentation on it was sparse because the
developers who knew how it worked were busy
developing, whether it was the framework,
or for a new feature for our websites.
And it also the universe of resources to get
help with it was scoped entirely to an extremely
small portion of our dev team which made it
hard for anyone who needed help to be self-sufficient.
On the flip side, popular open-source frameworks
came with the benefit of way more active and
visible communities to tap into for help.
Which not only means that you have a way bigger
pool of resources to get help from but it
also means that there is a community need
that you can give back to when you solve a
specific challenge, or interesting problem
yourself.
So, by then, it was easy enough to acknowledge
that our home-grown framework was no longer
the best tool for our team, or for the new
types of products and features that we were
building.
After spending some time on portfolio's development,
we turned our attention back to Behance.
In the time we had been building Adobe Portfolio,
our designers had been working on a new look
of the Behance website, and we wanted this
to make a big splash.
We wanted to it to be a release where the
look and feel of the entire website would
change for our users all at once.
Despite this once again, we still knew that
starting the whole thing over from scratch
was simply not going to be an option for us.
We had adopted modular JavaScript with require.js
and attempted to scope and componentise our
CSS as much as possible using BEM but the
truly scoped nature of JS and CSS was becoming
enticing for our increasingly modular website
and web apps.
The time was ripe for us to look for new technology.
In the same way that the industry at large
has a lot of opinions on the best tools to
use, so does any individual given dev team,
so, what we did to figure out what was going
to work best for us is hold group discussions,
lunch-and-learns, different learning sessions
for anyone interested where we would discuss
the pros and cons of CSS and JS solutions.
When we could get some kind of agreement on
which one seemed the most compelling, we would
actually try them out by building parts of
the website for them, specifically our admin
section of our websites which were just pages
that only employees can access for different
maintenance tasks but what it meant was we
could use these things in a near real-world
proving ground.
So, for Behance, we ultimately decided on
vue and CSS modules as our preferred tools,
and, once again, we continued to use a lot
of the same techniques for implementing new
technology that we had done in the past.
We exclusively built if you Norwegians using
these new tools and frameworks.
It meant they got to be in use immediately.
We rebuilt existing UI components such as
buttons and inputs using these new tools and
frameworks alongside their existing implementations
which could then be moved over to different
areas of the site as pose pages why updated
to use vue as well.
Perhaps most critically, we did it behind
feature flags, which is a set of code depending
on one user's code or another - it meant we
could build everything we needed alongside
the existing website without according about
interfering with it, while also still having
the ability to see all of this new stuff in
action in a production environment, even before
it was ready for its public debut.
So, this actually brings us to where we are
today: the website is not fully converted
to vue and CSS and JS, but we continue to
follow the same practices as we update and
develop new features, and, actually, as an
aside, although we are fairly recently into
our transition into vue, we've recently made
the decision to switch to React which I don't
have time to go into now, but we would be
happy to chat about with anyone after this
if you want.
So, if you look at the arc of CSS development
over the last eight years, it has changed
drastically.
In 2010, our biggest concerns were around
perfecting the slickest CSS gradient and getting
the website to look pixel-perfect to the mock-ups
that the designers gave us.
By 2018, not only are we concerned with how
the website looks, but we have to think about
how to optimise the code for the least repetition,
for the best browser performance, for how
it functions in the most browsers and devices
than I think we have ever had to deal with.
Since the CSS has become more closely intertwined
to our JavaScript and markup in modern frameworks
than ever before, our concerns are no longer
isolated to the CSS itself.
Because JavaScript technology and frameworks
moves so fast too, we end up having a much
bigger and more robust ecosystem than we need
to have a deeper understanding of.
Front-end development is hard.
Front-end engineering is hard.
But I encourage empathy in your decision-making
and interactions around it.
Every technical choice is relative, and there
is no right or wrong way to build a website.
So, in case the example so far didn't illustrate
the beautiful, unique messy path that web
development can take, I'm going to air a little
bit of Behance's dirty laundry in case any
of you have felt bad about the cancel to see
in your codebase's closet, maybe this will
help you feel you're not alone, and hopefully,
this is also therapeutic for me.
The figure one is we are still using three
different templating engines across the website
which is a relic of the transitions we've
made over time, and, depending on what page
you're viewing, you might be seeing all three
in action all at once.
This so happens to be the first page you see
when you log into our website.
I searched our codebase for some to-dos because
I thought there could be fun stuff in there.
I came across this one on the head tag of
our website.
"To do".
A lot of stuff included here which is unnecessary.
Cool!
That sounds bad, and also isn't particularly
actionable, but I had never noticed this before,
so I checked the git blame, and I was curious
to see how long this had been a problem for
... . [Laughter].
Okay!
While I was looking for the to-dos, I thought
I might as well clean up some of them while
I'm in here.
I found this one, and it says, "To do: remove
after statistics are fixed."
So, okay.
I found this in the CSS for a notifications,
and honestly, I could not figure out what
statistics has or ever had to do with our
notifications.
So, I checked the blame on this one also.
Still no idea.
So here's a little bit of a longer one.
This one says to do.
This is due to chrome 33 .0057, introducing
a phantom sub pixel.
Remove when fixed.
So, okay, that's a nice descriptive to-do
although it's not immediately why a whipped
property is a bad thing here.
It seems fine to me.
This is hopeful information.
Let's see if Chrome has updated at all since
this was written.
I went to Wikipedia to check when this specific
version of Chrome was released.
It was over three years ago.
Let's see what version Chrome is even up to.
Cool.
I left that one alone also.
We have a page on our website that we never
made responsive.
It is not even like it doesn't get traffic.
People visit this page.
Granted, it's not the most popular part of
the website, but we simply never prioritised
it.
Finally, my personal favourite, if you recall,
I said how we started committing compile to
the repo back in 2011, well, we did that for
over five years, and we only stopped doing
it about a year and a half ago, very long
after a lot of viable solutions had already
become available.
Talk about embarrassing!
If it sound like I'm saying our website is
kind of messy and imperfect, good - that is
what I'm saying!
But ultimately I'm actually proud on the work
on Behance, even though you know how the sausage
is made, it's not perfect, but the difference
between not perfect and bad is all in how
much you focus on it.
The closer you examine something, the worse
it seems.
But everything that we've built is the result
of hard work and smart ideas, and great teamwork.
I consider myself lucky to work with a driven
and compassionate group of people who care
deeply about the work that they create, the
products that we are building, and the impact
that it has on the lives of the people who
use it.
Ultimately, these are the things that I think
make the industry what it is.
These are the values that are way more important
than any of the latest frameworks or tools
or technologies [Applause]